لقد كان يومًا عاطفيًا للغاية بالنسبة
للجميع على ما أعتقد ، وأعتقد أنه في البداية
كان عدم تصديق الصدمة
كما تعلم عندما رأيت مسيحيًا ملقى
على الأرض
بلا حراك ، أعني أن تلك الصورة
التي ما زلت في رأسي
وهذا أمر مزعج
واه أنت خفت حقًا أه خفت
أسوأ ما كنت تعتقد أنه كان
سيموت
أممم لذا نعم لقد كان عاطفيًا للغاية
وآه نعم نحن سعداء للغاية وسعداء
لأنه على ما يرام
آه وأنه آه أنت  اعلم أنه على
قيد الحياة وبصحة جيدة وأنت تعلم آمل أن
يتمكن من تحقيق
انتعاش سريع وكان هناك الكثير من
الجدل حول
ما إذا كان يجب أن تلعب
أم لا تقول إنك كنت تتحدث مع
مارتن
برايثويت من كاسبر شمايكل الدنمارك ينتقد الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم قائلاً
في بيان يوم الاثنين.  تم اتخاذ
القرار بناءً على طلب قدمه
لاعبو الفريقين
، فهل كانت هذه هي الدعوة الصحيحة للعب على
خيارين سيئين ، إما
أن نبدأ المباراة في ذلك المساء أو
نلعب  في اليوم التالي ،
لذلك أعتقد أنني أتطلع إلى الأمام
ولأن هذا شيء من
المحتمل أن يحدث مرة أخرى وبغض النظر عن
عدد الاختبارات التي تجريها ، فسيتم
إجراؤها مرة أخرى وآمل أن يكون لدينا
نوع من
تنظيم أه لكيفية المضي قدمًا ومتى
نعم ، هذه الكلمات لها صدى
معي حقًا أن هذا قد
يحدث جيدًا بالفعل مرة أخرى ،
فما الدروس التي يجب تعلمها وما
قد يكون خيارًا محتملاً مقبولاً ،
ثم تقول إن هناك
خياران سيئان
ما كان يمكن أن يكون ناجحًا  أو إذا
تم إلغاؤها جميعًا وإلغائها جميعًا
إلى هذا الحد ،
أعتقد أن هذا سؤال صعب للغاية.
إذا كنت تعلم أن التعادل صفر صفر حصل
كلا الفريقين على نقطة واحدة ، ربما
ربما يكون هذا شيئًا ولكن لا أعتقد
أنه من الصعب
هذا شيء نحتاج إلى
التفكير فيه  ننتقل معًا ومن ثم
نأمل أن تعرف أن
المنظمات الكبيرة يمكنها أه
نعم اتخاذ نوع من القرار آه من الآن
فصاعدًا
رأينا تأثير ذلك على اللاعبين الدنماركيين
الذين شكلوا تلك
الحلقة هناك لحماية كريستيان هناك
على أرض الملعب في الوقت
الذي  يجب أن يشعر اللاعبون أيضًا
بالعواطف التي شعروا بها
وكيف تأثروا كيف يشعرون بأنهم
يقاومون الدموع بأنفسهم ،
كنت أتخيل
نعم بالتأكيد كان لدينا لاعبين يبكون
لاعبين كانوا
عاطفيين للغاية ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو نوع التجربة
التي سوف  ابق معك
إلى الأبد أقصد بغض النظر عما إذا كنت
في الملعب
أو في المدرجات أو أو تشاهد اه
تشاهد من المنزل
أه أعتقد هذا آه أنت تعرف هذه
الصورة في رأسك عندما ترى
إريكسون ملقى على الأرض بلا حراك
أعتقد هذا  هل
هذا لن يختفي أبدًا ، لذا فقد كانت
تجربة مؤلمة للغاية واه أنا
فقط تعرف شخصيًا آمل أن
يحصل الجميع على
المساعدة التي  في موقف
كهذا ،
أعني أنه
كان هناك الكثير من الأطفال الذين
يشاهدون اللعبة وأنت تعلم أنه سيكون
لدينا بعض الأسئلة
بعد شيء كهذا ، لذا آمل
أن تعرف أن جميع الآباء قد
خرجوا  هناك يتحدثون إلى أطفالهم
يشرحون
ما حدث وأه ونعم لأنه
من منظور عقلي
، إنه أمر صعب للغاية
لأنه
بالطبع هذه كانت مسألة حياة أو
موت أه
كرة القدم غير مهمة للغاية  عندما
يتعلق الأمر بشيء مثل هذا